your sons are playing my nuggets and my
nuggets are beating that ass we're about
to close it out I think I think they
play on Friday we're gonna seal the deal
are you sad about that do you want to
bet on it what are you feeling here you
know the last day it's not over it's not
over until it's over you know what I
mean
2023 hey I think yeah I'm champ this
year Sons champ that could be pretty
crazy uh I'll be champ regardless this
year so maybe if they need to do you
know run it next year we can do it but
hey it's not over till it's over they
need to get your ass in there and give
them a freaking pep talk that's what
they need to do
or a shooting guard one of the two I
don't want a shooting guard get in there
man Chris Falls first